so what a night what an honor and how
great was it to have those two ladies
give you that little entry speech oh my
god I mean it's amazing to me every day
when I go to the set and these are the
women I'm working with but for them to
present this tonight is such an honor I
loved how you also use this moment to
speak about climate change
who is Jane gonna get arrested with next
do you have any do you guys have any
famous friends you're gonna bring out
yeah you know what anybody who wants to
anybody who wants to know I know Grace
and Frankie is gonna be winding down
what can you tell us about how those
stories might add I'm not gonna tell you
what how this story is it gonna end
yeah and the truth is they donut they
don't really end I mean this is about
the time in your life and things can
keep changing and they do okay well
speaking of not ending everybody's
talking about a possible friends for you
is this happening on HBO max what is
going on I don't know do you really not
know I really don't know are you
involved in it potentially at all if it
happens we will certainly be involved in
it but what's holding it up why is it
why is it a question it's complicated
it's very complicated scheduling is it
what complicates it's everything it's
everything it's a very complicated thing
to do you've got a couple former friends
stars in the house Reese Witherspoon
I heard Brad Pitt's right there front
row yeah pretty cool did you say hi to
him I don't know if you guys have seen
the like I don't know how often you
spike I saw him at Netflix months ago
but I haven't gotten a chance to see him
tonight it's the show that touches
everybody it was so awesome to see your
reel and the incredible body of work
that you have done any type of show that
you do want to tackle next things you
haven't done yes honestly I love science
fiction I want to find something science
fiction there's a film we want to do
based on a book that I love we want to
do projects that are that we're
passionate about at this point there's
no reason to do anything we're not madly
in love with a comedy twist cuz you're
so you never know you never know I love
the movie Galaxy Quest I'm right me too
me too
I agree with you and anybody who you've
worked with who you'd want to bring back
and work with again or anybody who you
haven't gotten yet who you want to kind
of get on one of your shows oh my god
there are so many people I still want to
work with there's so many people I still
want to work with you know Octavia
Spencer is one of them who's being
honored tonight and in terms of wanting
to work with people again
there aren't many I wouldn't want to
work with again
[Music]